[Applause]
apology now
60 years of independence
we have not forgotten and we demand an
apology and reparations
[Applause]
[Music]
because it is an insult to us for these
young people to be here to try to
persuade us to keep the status quo in
place when our goal
is to loosen and remove the hands the
gloved hands of the queen from around
our necks so that we can breathe
respect us man apologize now
sending a shout out
to the duke and duchess of cambridge and
the entire royal family that reparation
time come no we are rebelled this is
living hell
oh madam queen help a knight to break
these powerless spells send lucifer back
to hell
chain him as well compensate and
repatriate and i to africa as well
and all will be well oh madame queen
oh madame queen
oh madame queen
let your royal visit me to re
let your royal visit be deliberate eye
and eye of these babylonian spells
thanks advance as well blessed lord
rastafari to the world and are yearning
for liberation
temptation frustration desolation water
situation
segregation degradation persecution what
a tribulation
[Music]
they began on independence economically
weak
after having been pinched by the
monarchy
today
on a benefit